hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast genomic profiling in
community practice ensuring the right
test for the right patient every time
presented by Cornell Shawn Chandra I'm
Alexis Krause of lab rats and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
labyrinth is a leading scientific social
patient events and webinars before I
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well if there's many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you or hearing the
presentation please click on the hop
just button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please joining me in welcoming
dr. Chandra I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you very
much for that introduction and it's my
pleasure to be here to speak to you
about genomic profiling and our
practical real-life experiences in being
able to deliver the practice of
precision medicine or precision oncology
in community practice one of the things
that has been just an absolute pleasure
as a practicing physician is to see the
growth of precision medicine and growth
of molecular pathology testing in being
able to enhance the
delivery of clinical care for patients
with cancer and community practice I
think it's a very very exciting time to
be a pathologist as well as to be
practicing medicine and anything to do
even properly with the practice of
precision medicine so a little bit about
myself my name is pronounced Andra I am
a pathologist by training and I trained
at NYU Medical Center up in New York
where I completed an anatomic and
clinical pathology fellowship and that
was that was followed by a key meto
pathology fellowship and then two more
fellowships I pursued at the University
of Texas MD Anderson Cancer Center in
Houston where I was fortunate to be
function as chief fellow and it was just
a wonderful experience of being able to
practice and learn from either leaders
or faculty who were on their way to
becoming leaders in the various segments
of pathology after which I transitioned
to a large practice in Milwaukee
Wisconsin where I was there for about
two and a half years I was a general
pathologist but also in charge of a lot
of the molecular testing and algorithmic
testing that took place in the practice
and I have since then transitioned to
path route where I have been for the
past six and a half years and in my
current role as chief medical officer I
provide clinical leadership to all of
the clinical pathology and genomic
pathology testing in our practice so
today what I wanted to do or the course
of the next about 30 to 45 minutes is to
give you an introduction to path group
and our organization who we are then I
wanted to talk about our genomic
profiling strategy and
some of the efforts that we were
successful in planning implementing and
executing in our practice and then I'd
like to get into some real-life case
studies just to show how genomic
profiling is used in clinical practice
in the context of myeloid disorders and
acute leukemia and I'll spend a little
bit of time talking about what those
disorders are and and really at the end
of the day I want you to all to have an
understanding of how we ensure that
though the right test is delivered for
the right patient at the right time and
and then there will be some time for
interactive discussions and questions
which I also look forward to so I wanted
to take a couple of minutes to tell you
about our organization I'm very excited
to be you know part of this organization
and it's been just you know a wonderful
ride during my six and a half year
tenure at path group and a little bit of
history about path group we are a large
and a diverse business and have been in
operations for nearly 50 years we are
located in the southeast specifically in
Nashville Tennessee and as you can see
from the graph below we provide the full
range of laboratory services in more
than 20 different states and more than a
500-mile radius around Nashville
Tennessee and these laboratory services
span anatomic pathology clinical
pathology as well as molecular pathology
which is an area that we've seen some
significant growth over the past six and
a half years since I've been here we
have more than 80 board-certified
pathologist and PhD level laboratory
directors with expertise and training in
every area of pathology and Laboratory
Medicine that you can imagine ranging
from
Dermatology to gastroenterology - you
know molecular pathology and precision
medicine we service more than 100
hospitals and ambulatory service centers
and thousands of physician offices on a
very routine basis currently we have
about 90,000 square feet of reference
laboratory space based in the National
Tennessee area where we provide services
that support not only our physicians who
are medical directors and pathologists
at these various hospitals that are part
of integrated regional healthcare
systems but also that support our
physicians in you know the thousands of
physician outpatient offices in our
practice ranges from bread-and-butter
primary care clinical practice to
women's health and infectious disease
testing and oncology testing women's
health and oncology are our two biggest
areas of concentration and where we see
the most growth the most testing as well
as the highest number of clients so
essentially we are one of the largest
privately owned pathology groups in the
country and we have a lot of experience
and hospital and physician client base
representing all specialties so really
it's been a great practice and I'm
fortunate to say that we continue to
grow on an annual basis and we you know
double in size every five to seven years
so because we are so large in size we
thoughtfully took some steps to invest
in the areas that we felt we're going to
be important for growth and we started
making these plans in 2011 and this was
led by a team of folks including myself
and senior executives as well as
scientific and laboratory directors and
our physicians and it's really hard to
encapsulate what we did on a slide but a
long story short it was a series of
committed efforts to build an enduring
molecular pathology division and a
number of efforts behind that including
recruiting top talent and fostering
leadership building the appropriate
culture of innovation a culture of
teamwork but at the same time a culture
of cost efficiency and I'll get into
later there is a lot of reimbursement
and regulatory pressure on the lab
industry so we have to be very
thoughtful and cost efficient in our
clinical operations but at the same time
deliver high-value and high-quality
health care services the other thing
that we did was to diversify our test
menu and expand our molecular pathology
test menu and focus on tests that add
value and what do I mean by value I mean
that these are tests that either improve
patient outcomes and/or decrease health
care costs by informing any combination
of diagnosis prognosis and/or therapy
and I'll get into you know some of the
tests that that we've deployed and and
launch but generally speaking we started
with our molecular testing and expanded
into genomics so what's the difference
between molecular testing and genomics
molecular testing traditionally looks at
one gene or one genomic region at a time
in genomic testing looks at multiple
genes or multiple genomic region and
regions at a time and we are in an era
from 2011 to the present where there's
been just an absolute explosion in
literature that highlights the clinical
utility of genomic aberrations and
and it's almost every week and every
month that there's a new publication
that's that's out there and that's
that's starting to really change the
practice of pathology and and now
requires additional tests in addition to
the traditional test that you know we
utilize as pathologists in our practice
the other thing that we've seen is an
explosion of drug development there are
now thousands of targeted therapies that
are being used in combination with
traditional chemo therapies in
combination with immuno oncology
therapeutics including so-called immune
checkpoint inhibitors immune checkpoint
modulator so there's been a lot of
advances in drug development and the
other thing I wanted to highlight is you
know the fact that high-throughput
sequencing is becoming more cost
effective you have what's so-called
next-generation sequencing platforms
that allow for more cost efficient
sequencing of hundreds to thousands of
genes at a fraction of cost that it
would take utilizing traditional
pathology methods so all of this has
combined together to you know create a
really great opportunity from a clinical
and medical perspective in providing
genomic testing for our patients and we
saw that a few years ago and we invested
in many of those promising technologies
and now have deployed them into our
practice across pretty much all of our
clinical service lines and these
technologies include high-throughput PCR
I'm not going to get into the technical
details that's beyond the scope of of
today's discussion but just important to
note that PCR is the backbone of
molecular pathology testing for
invented and conceived by Carrie Mullins
in the early 1980s and that's translated
into just a myriad of tests that have
really changed the practice of molecular
biology and molecular pathology and now
that's gone to the next level with
next-generation sequencing there are PCR
based as well as what's known as hyper
capture based technologies that allow
for next-generation sequencing testing
on a variety of platforms that are
available commercially today another
high throughput testing technology that
doesn't get a lot of attention because
it kind of hides in the limelight of
next-generation sequencing is saito
genomic microarray and very briefly that
allows us to look at global chromosomal
level copy number alterations and a
whole cancer genome level in a very cost
efficient fashion and so again to
summarize we've been successful in
implementing all of these tests into our
practice so in the area of oncology
which will be the focus of the remaining
slides of my presentation you know it's
important to know that the focus has
often been on the right therapy for the
right patient know at the right time and
sometimes that involves looking for that
needle in the haystack that as you can
see in the picture on the upper
right-hand side and you know that's for
example when we are looking for an
alchemy ininin on small cell lung cancer
all mutations occur less than 3% of
cases of advanced non-small-cell lung
cancer but we test for the possibility
of out rearrangements because patients
with alq
alterations respond exquisitely well to
fda-approved
therapy's that are directed against that
genomic operation let's talk about the
Silver Bullet in patients with
metastatic melanoma melanoma was once
considered a very very aggressive
disease that was very difficult to treat
and cure but many melanomas have a
mutation in a gene called B wrath and
melanomas with a B Ravi 600 e mutation
respond wonderfully well to targeted
therapies that that are directed against
the wrath or MEK pathway or map kinase
pathway and there are now fda-approved
b-raf as well as MEK inhibitors that are
approved for patients with advanced
melanoma that have a B reputation
genomic profiling may also involve
finding the rotten apples so you know
this is applicable in metastatic colon
cancer where patients with metastatic
colon cancer need to be evaluated for
the presence of a mutation and K wrasse
or n wrasse because if those patients
have a mutation in one of those genes
they are not going to respond to a very
toxic and expensive you know monoclonal
antibody therapy such as the tux the map
and and attuma map and so by identifying
these patients you're able to do cost
avoidance by testing for the genomic
aberrations and then a clinical decision
is made to either place a patient on a
regimen that contains that therapy or
not and because these are so expensive
it's been calculated that if every
metastatic colon cancer in the
healthcare system gets tested four
cameras or n wrasse the savings to the
healthcare system is on in the order of
magnitude of hundreds of millions of
dollars so for these reasons tests like
this that add value to the to the
healthcare system have been adopted and
integrated in into routine pathology and
laboratory workup of various tumors so I
wanted to spend some time talking about
clinical utility because the definition
of clinical utility differs depending on
who is asked to provide that definition
so pairs today now let me go back a
slide are very focused on ensuring that
the right genomic aberration is linked
to therapeutic benefit and that's been a
big focus on many of the payers
insurance carriers you know Medicare as
well as private insurance carriers in
that and that's great
that is one way that one can derive
clinical utility is to improve you know
therapeutic outcomes but in the world of
precision medicine and molecular
pathology it's oftentimes not just about
the right therapy for the right patient
at the right time we have to think about
it from a different perspective and a
perspective that is more patient centric
and so there is utility in establishing
a diagnosis for example and enhancing
the time to reach that diagnosis and
without an appropriate diagnosis you
cannot provide the right you know
therapy for the right patient at the
right time prognosis is also important
in addition to therapy and so I was
fortunate to be part of an upper of an
effort by the Association of molecular
pathology to not necessarily redefine
what clinical utility is but to cast a
broad light on really the various shades
that clinical utility can take on for
patients with both inherited diseases as
well as kin
sir and this was meant to just be an
educational opinion review article that
just highlights the benefits of
molecular testing it highlights the
importance of molecular professionals in
delivering precision medicine and
empowering the delivery of personalized
medicine but also just kind of you know
refocuses the discussion more from a
patient centric perspective and the main
theme of our arctic of our article and
publication is articulated in this slide
in that number one that the benefit of
molecular testing is not only about
therapy but it's also about diagnosis
and prognosis and that's very important
to know when deciding which tests to
bring online and which tests that are
actually going to you'll get reimbursed
the other point that I want to highlight
and this is a little bit more of a
practical perspective from my end is
that the diagnosis prognosis and therapy
are often times related so let's take
you let's take some examples of tumors
and in a you know bone marrow based
disorder like myelodysplastic syndrome
oftentimes he used a molecular test to
establish a diagnosis and and use it in
conjunction with the clinical in the
morphologic and all of the other
laboratory tests which you know may
include genomics as well to provide a
more precise diagnostic classification
and the latest publication and actually
the Bible for human illogic malignancies
and lymphoid tumors that's you know
published by the whu-oh there's there
are now a myriad of genes and some of
are required for diagnostic
classification of myeloid stem cell
disorders sometimes you might may have a
tumor that is widely metastatic and you
know there is you know it's difficult to
pinpoint where that tumor is coming from
and some of these molecular tests can
actually help pinpoint that you know
this is actually a tumor of a GI origin
and that is going to have downstream
implications with regard to therapy okay
so again you know diagnosis and therapy
are often related same goes with
prognosis so if you have you made a
diagnosis of a of a myeloid stem cell
disorder and some certain genomic
aberrations will tell you and will tell
a patient who's asking their doc doc
what what is my prognosis well certain
aberrations will will tell that this is
either going to behave indolently or
it's gonna fall somewhere in the middle
or it's gonna or it's a tumor that's
gonna behave very aggressively right and
so for example in a myeloid stem cell
disorder where you know patient is going
to have an aggressive clinical course
there are aggressive therapeutic
regimens that can be considered which
include but are not limited to you know
bone marrow transplant and then therapy
we've talked about therapy and in the
context of myeloid disorders now there
are FDA approved therapies for genomic
aberrations including idh - and acute
myeloid leukemia and flip 3 and acute
myeloid leukemia in patients with these
aberrations are have been shown to
benefit from therapy as directed against
those genomic aberrations so again
getting back to the paper the point was
just to highlight and broaden the scope
of clinical utility and the positive
impact that molecular tests have for
patients
so in our practice we took that to heart
and our goal was to be able to provide
any tests for any patient at any time
and and you know and so we you know took
the liberty to to you know make sure
that that we had a test that could be
applied for any patient with any cancer
and so this is a very simplistic summary
of all of the different assays that we
have and essentially you know for any
patient with with the cancer whether
it's initially a diagnostic no time
point or it's an advanced cancer you
know we designed panels and tests that
use complementary technologies that are
specific to the clinical as well as
system morphological context ranging
from you know single genes we've got
more than 35 different you know genes
and genomic regions that we could test
for it you know singly we've got very
basic panels and then more disease
specific panels for common cancers such
as colon cancer lung cancer and solid
tumors as well as hematologic
malignancies such as myeloid disorders
in chronic lymphocytic leukemia and then
we have broad panels that would be
similar to the ones that are offered by
foundation medicine and where you're
casting you know a broad net and you
know those tests are usually used in
patients that have refractory advanced
disease where they've filled standard
line therapies and they're looking for
that you know the genomic target and
potentially being placed into a clinical
trial in our practice the selection of
the molecular tests is very much
dependent on the clinical and workflow
to context and very often in our
pathology practice the the test that is
selected is is driven by pathologists
who are rendering diagnosis under the
microscope the image that you see here
on the left is essentially what a tumor
looks like under the microscope and this
is an example of a follicular lymphoma
it's a hematological malignancy and just
from your personal recollection this is
a high-grade tumor and based on that
context based on decisions that are
rendered at the microscope that leads to
downstream decision-making and a
utilization on one of these core
technologies that I've listed here such
as immunohistochemistry flow cytometry
cytogenetics Ida genomeics
fish insight - hybridization simple PCR
sequencing ranging all the way up to
next-generation sequencing and gene
expression profiling depending on the
clinical context that drives a set of
downstream decision-making points to
arrive at the right you know diagnosis
and render clinically useful prognostic
as well as therapeutic information and
you can see here that next-generation
sequencing and sign of genomic
microarray and some of these high
throughput technologies are just one of
the many tools that pathologists utilize
in order to work up tumors to render the
appropriate diagnostic prognostic and
therapeutic information so here's
another tumor this is an invasive colon
cancer and you know and this is an H and
E slide and an example of what a
pathologist would see under the
microscope and you know based on a
decision that renders this diagnosis you
know pathologist might you know utilize
immunohistochemistry to make sure that
it's you know of colon origin and then
use other technologies depending on if
this is a colon cancer initially at
diagnosis and if it's and if
then you have to do Lynch syndrome
testing which requires
immunohistochemistry as well as
microsatellite instability testing if
this is a metastatic colon cancer then
we may do KS and RasPi raf testing - you
know according to NCCN guidelines to
find prognosis as well as potential
response or lack thereof to therapy and
if this is a widely metastatic colon
cancer then you know you may want to do
a broader genomic profile that you know
looks for you know certain alterations
like her2 amplification and you know
patients with advanced metastatic colon
cancer with her2 amplification for
example stand to benefit from a number
of clinical trials that are available
today and this is an example that I
showed here of an invasive lung cancer
in a patient with advanced stage disease
where its standard of care to work a
tumor up with a thoughtfully selected
immunohistochemistry panel and then you
know it's important according to NCCN
guidelines to look at alterations and
genes including ichi far-out ross Wan
b-raf again invasive non-small-cell lung
cancer again if this is a widely
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer
you might want to cast a broader net so
again just wanted to highlight you know
the workflow how diagnosis is rendered
how it leads to downstream decision
making and test utilization and then on
the next slide our workflow here in our
practice we have custom-built
tools that help pathologists and
molecular pathologists interpret all of
the changes in DNA RNA and protein in
conjunction with the clinical and
morphologic context and interpret that
in the context of what's published out
there in the literature in and as well
as what's present in genomic knowledge
bases and we've built clinical and from
analytic tools that help us you know
render the diagnostic and prognostic as
well as therapeutic information and
integrates all of that you know through
integrative reporting this is an example
of one of our integrative summary
reports and as you can see in the
results section what we do is we
summarize the results from all of the
different technologies that are utilized
to profile a tumor then there's an
interpretation that's written by either
myself or or by one of my team mates who
may be a physician or you know an
appropriately trained PhD lab director
and then the report is signed off by a
physician molecular pathologist that's
you know board-certified and and then an
articulation of the therapeutic
Association so as you can see on the
left hand side in articulation of the
prognostic associations in tabular
format and then wherever appropriate
clinical trials clinical trials are very
important and you know some clinical
trials may significantly improve the
outcome of patients with you know both
localized as well as advanced cancer so
so incorporation of clinical trials and
examples of clinical trials are things
that in the appropriate context we also
include in the report and then there's a
list of references these reports are
usually one to two pages long we want to
be able to present them in a lucid
format that is educational
that's not overly burdensome for the end
user and oncology client but is will
give them enough information to given
them an idea of the molecular biology of
the tumor and then start to articulate
and map out you know next steps and
treatment steps based on diagnostic
prognostic as well as other information
that's rendered in
in the reports that's an example of the
report that we've designed and you know
we're taking a lot of thought and we
continue to get feedback and are looking
to you know take this reporting to the
next level so our strategy fortunately
has paid off and I wanted to show this
slide here for a couple of reasons you
know want to show you results of our
efforts from 2011 to 2017 and and this
is just in the area of PCR and
next-generation sequencing testing which
is just one part of our molecular
pathology practice but indicative of
just the amount of growth and demand of
molecular profiling in you know in
cancer patients molecular as well as
genomic profiling and as you can see
here in 2011 we didn't have a lot of
assays every color that you see here
represents a new assay that we've
introduced and deployed validated and
develop validated and deployed into our
practice and every color here you see
represents a new assay and it's color
color-coded and highlights the
importance of test menu diversification
but also you know highlights the demand
for you know molecular testing and
genomic profiling and the continued
growth based on you know all of the
publications and all the new literature
that's you know coming about in this
area so I will also say that most of the
tests that you see here at least in our
practice have been this single gene test
and the focused you know profiling
because you know they're they're well
defined they're defined by NCCN
guidelines and high-impact publications
and most clinicians and oncologist know
what to do with a care ass or b-raf
remember ass mutation and menace
colon cancer and so in community
practice we see a lot of just single you
know ala carte ordering as well as more
focused profiling and you know again we
look at a cancer patient at the point of
diagnosis or metastatic disease or if
they have relapsed refractory breast
disease are very advanced disease it's
important to think of those cancer
patients across this diagnostic and
therapeutic continuum so that's what we
see today and then in relapsed
aggressive tumors we're seeing broader
utilization of broad panels and we see
you know tests that get sent out for
foundation medicine some of those tests
we do and there are other commercially
available tests that are available in
addition to ours and and the other
organizations that I mentioned now that
that's the practice today I will say
that this is going to change over the
next few years because of this continued
explosion of genomic information and
identification of clinical utility we're
going to see therapies approved agnostic
Lee you know - tissue site of origin and
and you know some recent therapies
parallelism map comes to mind has been
fda-approved for any metastatic solid
tumor that demonstrates evidence of
microsatellite instability which can be
measured by either PCR or
next-generation sequencing techniques
and then you have other biomarkers like
tumor mutational burden and n track
fusions and just whole slew other
alterations where it doesn't matter what
tumor it is it's important to identify
those genomic aberrations so as the
field matures Alice's literature matures
we're gonna see more and more broader
genomic profiling over time the other
thing that we're gonna see is an
increase in liquid biopsy testing we're
seeing this today and
I think that there's going to be a happy
medium where when a tissue biopsy isn't
available or when there needs to be
additional information in addition to
the tissue biopsy that we're going to
resort to so-called liquid biopsy and
these are commercially available tests
that are non-invasive that are performed
on peripheral blood and look for
mutations in peripheral blood and you
know there are advantages and
disadvantage advantages to that
obviously tumor has to be advanced
enough to shed tumor DNA in the
peripheral blood so that you can pick it
up by a commercial software but also you
know combination of approaches may
address an issue of tissue and molecular
heterogeneity which is essentially the
fact that one tumor may have in a
patient with a widely metastatic cancer
you know one site or one one of those
tumors may have a certain molecular
signature and another site may have a
completely different you know signature
that similar sometimes but can also be a
completely different and so that that
can be a challenge in you the workup of
patients with cancer and I think with
liquid biopsy testing and broader
genomic profiling and complementary
testing approaches we're going to be
able to overcome that and again continue
to render diagnostic prognostic as well
as therapeutic information the
therapeutic decision making can be
placing a patient on the chemotherapy or
not a targeted therapy immuno oncology
therapeutics and a clinical trial and
we'll get more into the reasons for why
you know that's important later on in
the discussion so what I'd like to do is
now get a little laser focus and talk
about myeloid disorders and acute
leukemia just a brief background on
myeloid disorders
these can include chronic as well as
acute myeloid diseases which are
generally
bone marrow based diseases that and the
diagnosis is rendered usually either in
peripheral blood but more often by doing
a bone-marrow biopsy and looking at the
cells under the microscope and these
diseases range from on the chronic side
you know myelodysplastic syndrome
myeloproliferative neoplasms overlap
myelodysplastic myeloproliferative
neoplasms and they can be low-grade or
they can be high-grade and then those
disorders tend to tend to you know
gravitate to and evolve into acute
leukemia which is a medical emergency
and you know these patients need to be
hospitalized and they need to be treated
you know with chemo therapeutic regimens
which may or may not be directed against
genomic aberrations so in our practice
again we have implemented algorithmic
test utilization and you know when a
client sends us a bone marrow sample to
work or you know any tissue biopsy
sample to you know render a diagnosis of
the human illogic malignancy there's a
box that they check off and that allows
us to appropriately workup the case
utilizing you know what what's
recommended in guidelines ash guidelines
and CCA guidelines w-h-o guidelines in
accordance with the clinical and histo
morphologic context by one of our
physicians that's board-certified and
again all the results are placed in a
comprehensive report that's integrative
similar to the report that i outlined
earlier and we've developed these
algorithms based on high-impact
publications NCCN guidelines some of
which i'm going to review with you in
the next few slides and it's important
because all of these different
technologies really plays a part you
know the traditional laboratory
technologies as well as the advanced
genomic profile
technologies they all have a role to
play in the appropriate work of myeloid
disorders and acute leukemia and that
was the focus of our publication that
was you know presented and and published
rather in October of last year and what
we did was we took a few hundred of our
myeloid disorders that were worked up by
our group and then in partnership with
an oncology group based here in
Nashville Tennessee and you know other
you know contributors and we looked at
the clinical utility that advanced
genomic profiling techniques add to the
standard workup of these myeloid
disorders in acute leukemia utilizing a
traditional pathology technologies what
I'm what do I mean by traditional
pathology technology is
immunohistochemistry conventional
cytogenetics you know fish testing
single analyte PCR testing how do those
stack up compared to high-throughput
genomic profiling technologies like
next-generation sequencing and side of
genomic microarray that was the focus of
the paper we looked at hundreds of cases
where we work those tumors up you know
with high throughput technologies and
one of the main points of the paper is
articulated here in those cases where
there was clinical or morphologic histah
morphologic pathology based suspicion of
a myeloid disorder 227 of those that
that were negative by traditional
pathology techniques such as
conventional side of genetics and fish
and sometimes sometimes single analyte
PCR the next-generation sequencing and
site of genomic microarray was positive
in 76 percent of those cases so in 76
percent of those cases there was
information
that was rendered that either had
diagnostic prognostic and or therapeutic
significance and that's how we defined
clinically actionable alterations than
in this paper that that we published
three quarters of the cases that were
negative by traditional techniques were
positive so does this mean that you
don't need to do the traditional
techniques and in and you only do the
high throughput techniques that question
is answered in the following slide what
you see here is a distribution of
abnormal cases based on technologies in
red is next generation sequencing in
green is sighted genomic microarray and
blue and purple are the traditional
techniques the conventional side of
genetics and fish testing and you can
see you know and this is distributed
across all the different diseases acute
myeloid leukemia
myelodysplastic syndrome MDS
myeloproliferative neoplasms overlap
mileages plastic and myeloproliferative
neoplasms and you can see that the
detection rate of aberrations is either
equivalent or superior to traditional
pathology techniques across all of the
different disease states with the
highest difference noted in overlapped
myelodysplastic myeloproliferative
neoplasms including CML which is a
disease known as chronic myeloid
monocytic leukemia and
myeloproliferative neoplasms i mean in
in but you can also see in acute myeloid
leukemia for example that
next-generation sequencing is positive
86% of the time as compared to 52% of
the time that fish is positive now what
we also saw in our practice were that
there were a select number of cases that
the traditional techniques conventional
cytogenetics and Finnish yielded the
appropriate clinical clinically
actionable information whereas the other
tests were non-contributory
um and you know when we see that most
prominent another disease state that I
don't include here but the the point
that I'm trying to make is that every
one of these tests is important in the
routine workup of patients with myeloid
disorders and keep myeloid leukemia and
in those cases where let's say fish was
positive and next-generation sequencing
or aside of genomic microwave was
positive
there was additional information that
was rendered so you may have a patient
that would have been classified a
certain way either from a prognostic or
a diagnostic standpoint but the
additional layer of information that was
rendered by these high throughput
techniques would have changed either the
prognostic classification or the
diagnostic classification and I'll get
into a couple of case studies that you
know highlight that more prominent
prominently so those were the two themes
of our paper and it's available it was
published in cancer genetics it was
published in October of last year and
drove a lot of the algorithmic decision
making and how we work up these tumors
routinely in in our practice but I will
say that there's been just a plethora of
publications and you know the the one
that I've Illustrated here on the
left-hand side it was published in 2012
and you know it's been six years since I
was published but it highlights a very
important point that I wanted to bring
out here and that was the enhanced
prognostic risk stratification of
genomic profiling
- you know better render diagnostic
prognostic and and therapeutic and
information for patients so in the
traditional model where you know you
don't do genomic profiling and you do
the traditional laboratory tests in
patients with acute leukemia you can see
on the left hand side through the side
of genetic classification that 19
percent of your patient cohort fall into
a favorable risk category
63% fall into the intermediate and 18%
into the unfavorable so you've got a
pretty uneven distribution of patients
into the favorable intermediate and
unfavorable risk category you add in
molecular testing and genomic profiling
and you can see that your prognostic
classification which drives downstream
therapy addictive decision making
changes so your favorable cohort went
from nineteen percent to twenty six
percent and your unfavorable went from
eighteen percent to thirty nine percent
and so you've taken patients who would
have been lumped into kind of this waste
bucket intermediate category you've
identified and reclassified those
patients into them either having a
favorable or an unfavorable you know
clinical course and there's another
article that was published in you know
2016 that you know takes genomic
profiling you know to the next level and
really provides an integrated
classification based on clinical
variables demographics copy number
alterations again copy number
alterations are alterations detected by
sighted genomic microarray and you know
fusions point mutations you know that
may be detected by a next-generation
sequencing and provided you know an
immigrated new classic classification
and you can see that integrating the
genomic profiling you know has a much
better outcome of being able to better
classify these diseases which again
drives the diagnosis to practices but
also you know drives therapeutic
decision making and I encourage you all
to you know you read all of these papers
and there are a plethora of them in
myeloid disorders in acute leukemia and
these are just a couple of them that I
have mentioned here you know for
purposes of our discussion today again
this paper divided acute leukemias into
at least
nine different genomic categories it
might be more more than nine different
categories but based on the genomic
operations that had prognostic as well
as therapeutic implications because of
all of these publications now the NCCN
guidelines have evolved over the past
few years and in the setting of
myeloproliferative neoplasms you can see
here that now there's more than a
handful of genes that are important to
identify because it changes the
prognosis in patients with these
disorders take this gene a axial one a
SXL one a mutation in that gene doesn't
matter what myeloid disorder you have
there are almost patients with mutations
in that gene are almost universally
associated with an aggressive clinical
course high likelihood of therapeutic
failure and a high risk of
transformation to acute leukemia same
goes with myelodysplastic syndrome these
are recent NCCN guidelines for
myelodysplastic syndrome and you can see
here that there's more than 15 genes
that are important potentially in the
workup of myeloid disorders so in a
context where traditional techniques are
negative and you employ high-throughput
technologies either next-gen sequencing
or microarray and you detect a mutation
in one of these genes in the appropriate
context it actually helps to make the
diagnosis by itself it doesn't make the
diagnosis but in the right clinical in
the right morphologic context detecting
these mutations supports that diagnosis
but more you know equally important
there's prognostic information that's
rendered and for patients with high-risk
myelodysplastic syndromes where skin and
therapies aren't working they may may be
considered candidates for bone marrow
transplant and it's important to know
that bone marrow transplant you know
it's an expensive medical procedure it's
fraught with you know complications and
there are also no genomic aberrations
that will give a clinician a red flag
that you know this is a mutation that's
actually associated with a poor outcome
in those patients that are transplanted
so there's a lot of opportunity for cost
avoidance and being able to ensure that
you know the right therapies rap match
to the right patient at the right time
and the folks that wrote the acute
myeloid leukemia guidelines in season
guidelines were smart
Damon lists all the genes because you
know there's there's so many genes now
that are important in the diagnostic
classification and rendering prognostic
information and or you know therapeutic
information in acute leukemia so I'll
just read out loud here the NCCN
guidelines for acute myeloid leukemia
and they recommend bone marrow with
conventional cytogenetics that's a
traditional pathology technique
conventional karyotyping cluster - fish
and molecular analyses to include kit
flip 3mp m1c EBP alpha and other
mutations and when you go to the
American Society of Hematology guideline
recommendations that were recently
published there's a growing list of
genomic aberrations that are important
to identify in the routine a workup of
these tumors so again lots of literature
out there that's now being integrated
into evidence-based guidelines including
NCCN w-h-o and you know guidelines by
American Society of Hematology for acute
myeloid leukemia so what I'd like to do
is I wanted to talk about some cases
that are you know important to
illustrate the clinical utility this is
a 71 year old who had a high white blood
cell count and I won't get into the
details I'll give you you know the the
main points of what I'm trying to
articulate on each slide over here
this is a photo macabre low power view
of the peripheral blood there's a lot of
cell
that you can see here they are white
blood cells they are granulosus it
excels on higher power here you can
appreciate that there are granulocytes
many of them are so-called left shifted
which means that they are not mature
they're not completely immature they're
not you know blasts but they are stuck
in the middle of being mature white
blood cells and immature you know white
blood cells and there are some changes
that you see here that a pathologist
would call you know atypical there was
there cytologic atypia I wouldn't say
there is rank dysplasia and that's
important in the you know additional
work of these tumors this is an example
of a bone marrow biopsy this is what he
meadow pathologists like myself see
under the microscope the very light pink
tissue that you see here is bone and
then this cells what's you know the
purple nucleus those are all of the
cells in your bone marrow and what you
know we're supposed to tell when we're
looking at the slides from the
microscope is how cellular is the bone
marrow and you know that's based on the
amount of fat cells which are the white
spaces that are most best appreciated on
the upper left hand slide the circular
white spaces are fat cells and all of
the other purple cells are the bone
marrow cells and so this is a very hyper
cellular marrow and indicative of a
myeloid stem cell disorder just to
summarize the the testing that was
performed the conventional testing
pathology testing including single gene
analysis they were all within normal
limits over here a pathologist who looks
at this the first thing that comes to
mind and the differential diagnosis is
chronic neutrophilic chronic myelogenous
leukemia CML and the tests were
essentially excluded that because there
was no BCR Abel or Philadelphia from
so that was detected here rather there
was a CSF 3r mutation that was detected
and as well as an SRS F 2 mutation there
were also some changes that we saw on
site of genomic microarray which I won't
get into the details so that completely
changed the diagnostic considerations
and and the differential diagnosis now
included chronic neutrophilic leukemia
which is a mimic er of CML but it's a
it's a very different disease on a
molecular biology level and the other
differential diagnosis was atypical CML
and the diagnosis for that is rendered
when BCR Abel is negative and you've got
evidence of dysplasia I mentioned that
we did not have dysplasia so so we were
able to exclude that and the diagnosis
in this case was chronic neutrophilic
leukemia now when you look at the
literature out there less than 200 cases
and this is a few years ago were
reported worldwide and you know I've got
a comment that'll speak to that later on
and in one of my slides but first what I
wanted to do is articulate what's the
clinical utility what's the clinical
significance well we were able to render
a more precise diagnosis and in fact CSF
3 our mutation is required by the WHL as
a diagnostic bullet point to help
establish a diagnosis of chronic
neutrophilic leukemia it's required for
diagnosis these tumors usually have an
aggressive clinical course they do not
respond to BCR Abel inhibitors that are
typically used to treat you know
Philadelphia chromosome positive chronic
myelogenous leukemia so they tend to
have an aggressive clinical course and
and you know patients wind up succumbing
to their disease now the literature has
showed that depending on the type of CSF
3r mutation that activates a different
molecular pathways for which either
jak-stat inhibitors or Sark Lin
inhibitors may be affected and this
particular mutation was is known to
activate the jak stat pathway and so
you've got
drugs like works a lot in there that are
fda-approved and other disease states
that are now being utilized you know in
a investigational clinical trial context
- for patients with this mutation and
and so again different diagnosis
different prognosis and a different
therapy that was rendered from the
genomic findings the next case is a 76
year old gentleman with anemia and had
an anemia and a clinical presentation
that raised the possibility of
myelodysplastic syndrome the morphologic
findings that are summarized here they
said they would support a diagnosis of
mild a dysplastic syndrome and that
there were changes in which I'll show on
the next slide and there was another
finding of ill-defined lymphoid
aggregate so what does that look like
here are the pathology images on the
left hand side you know the left
photomicrographs show will hypercellular
marrow and the bottom left shows nuclear
changes affecting the erythroid the red
blood cell did white blood cell lineages
that would indicate you know clinical
morphologic evidence of my love
dysplasia on the right hand side you had
these lymphoid aggregates those blue
cells that you see here are our
lymphocytes they are atypical and that
they kind of all look like each other
and and that aggregates are ill-defined
you can't draw a circle around it the
it's kind of insidious in how its you
know infiltrating into the bone marrow
you go to the next slide again the
conventional technologies and laboratory
tests were negative and or you know non
diagnostic and the next generation
sequencing testing that was performed we
found three mutations and I'm gonna get
into the diagnostic prognostic and
therapeutic significance this required a
call with the clinician to talk about
and walk through the clinical utility of
the finding so the first thing is that
we were able to you confidently render a
diagnosis of myelodysplastic syndrome
and some of the mutations are actually
associated with an aggressive clinical
course and there are molecular pathways
that are altered as well as therapies
that are in various stages of clinical
development that could potentially be
utilized in this patient should standard
therapies not work but the other really
fascinating thing was that we made a
second diagnosis of early lympha plasma
CITIC lymphoma it turned out that this
patient had some other clinical findings
including an IgM gammopathy that would
indicate you know early live a plasma
static lymphoma but we also found a
mighty 88 L to 65 mutation and then in
conjunction with the lymphoid aggregates
that I showed you earlier
we were able to let the clinician know
that this patient actually has a second
malignancy and and really it was just
game-changing not only were we able to
render one diagnosis we were actually
able to render two diagnoses and so
these are some results that I wanted to
share in our workup of acute myeloid
leukemia the first case shows that you
got a patient with acute myeloid
leukemia with the jak2 mutation and you
wouldn't think that you would see that
in a patient with acute myeloid leukemia
jak2 mutations are actually diagnostic
for many my chronic myeloid disorders
but in this case what this tells us is
that this is a patient that actually had
an underlying myeloid disorder and then
their disease took off and became an
acute leukemia and that's important to
note because these patients actually do
not do very well with standard induction
and consolidation chemotherapy there's a
high degree
resistance a high degree of relapse and
there are now actually FDA approved
therapies that are more aggressive well
they're more better applicable for
patients with aggressive AML's
and you know one such therapy has been
FDA approved for emails with underlying
myelodysplasia related changes so again
there's diagnostic prognostic and
therapeutic information that's rendered
the case below same thing you had a
mutation or profile that you know
suggests an underlying myeloid stem cell
disorder but as you can see that we also
found an ID h2 mutation and now there's
actually fda-approved therapy that can
be utilized for an AML patient you know
with with this mutation so again these
are just two cases where the testing you
know really you know changed the
potential outlook for the patient but
also changed potentially the clinical
management decision of the patient this
is one of my favorite cases this is a 55
year old with CML that evolved to a
precursor b-cell acute lymphoblastic
leukemia we did the genomic profiling
and we found a number of mutations that
I articulated over here so it was very
interesting because the mutation in gene
equal one we were able to go to the
genomic databases in the literature and
the NCCN guidelines and there was enough
literature to suggest that this leukemia
this particular acute leukemia would
respond to a drug known as inabnitt and
so the patient you know was placed on
pen active and you know within you know
weeks this patient had just an amazing
response and was able to you know
eradicate you know the tumor cells from
their bone marrow and what's also really
great is that is that this is a patient
with an acute leukemia that has other
operations as well as I mentioned before
i th - mutations there are now very
effective
you know therapies that both ith
inhibitors as well as bcl-2 inhibitors
that have shown promise in acute
leukemias with idh1 or ith - mutation so
now the oncologist has a map of you know
here's here's how this patient is going
to be treated but in the event that the
patient does relapse I've got you know
option number two and potentially option
number three in my back pocket and you
know it's just really exciting for
patients that with these aggressive
tumors to have some you know very
favorable options I'll just summarize by
saying that that myeloid disorder is an
acute leukemia are on a continuum that's
really important to know that from a
molecular biology level when you look at
a disease like myelodysplastic syndrome
on the left hand side there are certain
genes that help tell you that it's you
know gene mutation that helped telling
you that it's a myelodysplastic syndrome
and any of those diseases whether it's
mileages plastic syndrome essential
thrombocythemia polycythemia vera
primary myelofibrosis any of these
diseases can evolve to acute myeloid
leukemia or acute lymphoblastic leukemia
and on the right hand side are more
myeloproliferative neoplasms and an
overlap myeloproliferative
myelodysplastic neoplasms and when
you've got a patient with an AML you
have to design a testing strategy that
incorporates all of the genomic
aberrations that you can see in all
these other diseases because if you pick
that up in the AML you can oftentimes
tell where that AML came from and
whether it's a de novo AML or it's an
email with underlying myeloid and my
let's plane are willing to changes it's
really important to make that
distinction because it
therapeutic impacts I wanted to leave
you just with that notion as you know
major theme of myeloid disorders so
running short on time here just to
summarize there's an absolute robust
growth in molecular testing and I think
this is going to continue for the
foreseeable future and I think
laboratories like ourselves are looking
at ways to diversify our you know test
menu and with a focus on clinical
utility and on tests that really move
the needle for patients I will say that
there are significant headwinds and
challenges you know it is a competitive
market there are a lot of commercial
labs that are out there there's also a
lot of reimbursement and regulatory
pressure which has led many laboratories
including ours to focus on
cost-efficient laboratory operations I
am optimistic that the reimbursement and
regulatory challenges will be overcome
as more and more literature supports the
clinical utility as we you know take our
lens off and look at clinical utility
from a patient centric perspective I
think you know the future is very bright
and a really exciting time you know to
be in this field and in the field of
precision medicine precision oncology so
I wanted to thank you for your time as
you can tell I'm very passionate about
this topic and you know I'm very excited
for you know where the field is gonna go
over the next few years and I think
there are challenges but those will be
overcome with time so thank you again
and I'll be happy to take questions
thank you dr. Chandra for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left your
presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is what
are the opportunities and challenges for
reimbursement well that's a that's a
great question it's a bit of a loaded
question so let me start with the
challenges I think now the field of
molecular pathology with regard to
cancer genomics is relatively new and
the literature has really exploded over
the past few years and you know the
payers have a bit of time to catch up
and you know really understand the value
that you know this testing brings to the
care of patients
there are many molecular tests that are
reimbursed but there's also many
molecular tests that face young
reimbursement challenges as well as
pressure that being said over time once
we see more data on outcomes as well as
other metrics like time to render a
diagnosis or establishing the right
diagnosis which drives the right
prognostic classification and ultimately
therapy those are all interconnected as
long as we continue to focus on that and
the clinical utility I think that we
will overcome the reimbursement
challenges ultimately what we need to do
and I see this as an opportunity is to
tie the the molecular testing to
downstream healthcare costs and so when
you are able to render a test that lets
a clinician know that a multi hundred
thousand dollar therapeutic regimen is
not going to work that's a lot of cost
that you've avoided and when we can you
know come full circle and you know
capture all of that will realize of the
true value of molecular testing our next
question is why should payers reimburse
for testing
that places a patient in onto a clinical
trial would that be considered
experimental a great question and let me
rephrase the question so if you're if
you're performing a molecular test and
the patient then decides to place a
patient on the clinical trial well isn't
that experimental so they were
investigational why should I pay
attention to pay for their number of
reasons one is that yes the clinical
trial and you know there are numerous
clinical trials that are out there both
in academic medical centers as well as
community practice the clinical trials
are investigational however the tests
that are utilized by clinicians to find
these targets next generation sequencing
tests they are very well validated
according to rigorous standards some of
these may be FDA approved vast majority
of them are approved and regulated by
CLIA cap standards which is ultimately
regulated by CMS and most laboratories
have to perform very stringent efforts
to be able to offer a test and I won't
get into the details but it involves
things like ensuring analytical and
clinical validity and making sure that
the test is precise it's reproducible
and all that needs to be worked up in
you know validation summary that's
signed off you know by a laboratory
director so there's a very robust
process already in place that allow for
the provision of genomic tests in
accordance with evidence-based
guidelines by in a society's preeminent
medical society so the test is actually
not investigational it is a you know
clinically validated and
and a test that is clinically meaningful
in when utilized responsibly in the
appropriate clinical and morphologic
context second thing I wanted to say is
that often times and entities and
guideline senses as well is that the
best chance for patient survival can
oftentimes be in a clinical trial and so
you know that that's kind of a bit of a
mindset because we often think of
clinical trials as being applicable only
to a patient that has failed like three
therapies but no there are a lot of
promise in clinical trials utilizing
targeted therapies and amino oncology
therapy therapies that a patient know
may benefit from and to be eligible for
those clinical trials they may need to
have a certain type of genomic
aberration as detected by one of these
technologies and dr. Chandra it looks
like we have time for one more question
where do you see genomic profiling
headed in the next five to ten years a
great question it's hard to predict the
future at least what I've seen in the
past five years if that's a harbinger
for what things are going to be in the
next few years I you know we can use
that as as a potential model I see
genomic profiling continuing to get
integrated into the practice of
pathology and Laboratory Medicine I
focus today on on hematoma thorgy
myeloid disorders in acute leukemia
where this testing has become integrated
and has become standard of care we're
gonna see this across all of the other
different areas of pathology from when
gee I thought jet pathology all the
surgical pathology sub specialties like
thoracic pathology we're starting to see
that integration today and that's going
to continue you know over all of the
surgical pathology disciplines and then
there's
also going to be integration across
clinical pathology disciplines in the
setting of microbiology for example
there are now a lot of molecular
techniques that become standard of care
and that's going to continue to grow and
we're also going to see a blurring of
what was originally you know
traditionally anatomic pathology what
was clinical pathology what's molecular
pathology you know there are going to be
you know tests that
and efforts that are going to span
really all of those areas and blur the
boundaries you know between them and
I'll just conclude by saying you know
there's recent literature for example on
you know the microbiology signature also
known as microbiome signature in your
gut in your stomach and your intestines
and that signature actually can help
predict who's going to respond to a
immuno Oncology therapeutic directed
against a cancer and you know things
like that are mind-blowing but that's
the way that you know the field is you
know evolving and so I think the
future's bright I think that we've got
to engage educate all of the
stakeholders including the pair's and
ultimately a focus on you know the tests
that are gonna add the value by again
decreasing health care costs and or
improving outcomes by rendering
diagnostic prognostic or therapeutic
information I would like to once again
thank dr. Tundra for his presentation I
would also like to thank lack rates for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through July of 2018 you'll receive an
email from labyrinth letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today the five event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye thank you